israel and turkey are restoring full
diplomatic ties after years of discord
both sides will reappoint ambassadors
for the first time in four years but the
turkish government says despite the
thorin relations it won't be abandoning
the palestinian cause well russell cerda
is live for us now in istanbul russell
can you give us an idea of just how
significant this is
well the full restoration of the
diplomatic relations between ankara and
tel aviv is is quite a milestone in
relations between the two countries and
this is coming after intense talks
between the uh the the israeli and the
turkish officials through the last year
so both countries have enough reasons to
to normalize the relations for and
israel is is facing the regional trance
turkey is facing the original threat
particularly israel is regarding iran as
a security threat and regards turkey
also to be a counterbalance to this
threat for turkey it is facing the
threats from the middle east
mediterranean and particularly in syria
and having the israeli support in these
fields uh is going to be beneficiary for
ankara this is ankara's perspective also
um on the other hand uh we can see that
just there is a less than a year to the
presidential election in turkey and
turkish economy is struggling so
last year turkey has embarked on a
diplomatic push to to to amend the ties
with the regional rivals such as uh
egypt uh united arab emirates saudi
arabia and israel so this normalization
of the relations between ankara and tel
aviv should be taken or considered in
these contexts while there is less than
a year to the presidential election
president erdogan's priority is a
recovery of the economy and putting good
relations with with these regional
powers he thinks that this is going to
help the turkish the turkish economy
just in regards to the timing uh why now
well to be honest it's not a surprise uh
for for those who are following uh these
issues so the relations between israel
and turkey got frayed in 2008 when
israel attacked on gaza and killed more
than 200 palestinians but it was the
breaking point was
the israeli attack on my murmur flotilla
which killed 10 turkish citizens and
injured several others and right after
that both ankara and tel aviv they have
withdrawn their ambassadors from the
capitals and relations have seen hit at
the lowest level of almost the entire
history of both countries but last year
last year both countries have uh
embarked on the diplomatic push and we
have seen that in march israeli
president isaac herzog was in turkey and
then the turkish foreign minister in may
visited
israel then the israeli prime minister
came to turkey in june and this is a
continuation of these talks and
diplomatic efforts so last time when the
israeli prime minister was in ankara
both
both the turkish foreign minister and
israeli foreign ministers reiterated
that they are going to appoint the
ambassadors soon and that was expected
so today we have seen that this decision
has been taken by both capitals frazzled
soda thank you very much for that
well let's take a closer look at the
background to the rift between the two
countries relations were downgraded in
2010 after israeli commandos killed 10
people when they stormed a turkish
vessel bound for gaza
then in 2018 both countries expelled
each other's invoice in a dispute over
israel's use of deadly force against
protesters in gaza
more recently relations have improved
last november turkey released an israeli
couple who'd been detained in istanbul
on spying charges and israeli president
isaac herzog visited turkey in may
calling the trip the beginning of a new
era
well let's bring in navi bassan he's an
assistant professor and political
analyst he joins us via skype from
istanbul thank you very much for joining
the program
first of all can we take it back a step
can you give us just a little bit of
context around
why diplomatic ties were cut in the
first place and and just how that played
out
well actually uh that that was uh the
diplomatic ties were cut since 2018 when
israel
you know attacked over the demonstrators
actually they were protesting against
u.s embassy moving
into jerusalem and recognizing it as
capital
let's remember that over 60 people uh
got killed as a result and of course we
should also remember that towards the
end of 2018 uh
due to turkey's
efforts international efforts to stop
this uh happening so it came in a really
uh bad time so then since then turkey
and israel uh uh did not have diplomatic
relations but of course as uh as you
said uh earlier that uh there is a
israeli president's visit to ankara in
march
this year was a turning point in
relations because both leaders uh
encouraged uh bilateral development or
further developing bilateral relations
and they signaled very strongly
that the relations sooner or later would
normalize quote unquote
in my view this is as as a citizen of
turkey this is long overdue and you know
relations uh between countries always
have ups and downs and certainly between
israel and turkey and you know as being
in crisis is not paternal friendship is
not eternal too so let's remember also
last uh april there was a scheduled
visit to charles schwall's visit to
israel that was delayed a bit but there
were like really concrete steps so today
yes it came as a a surprise as a you
know in turkey i'm following the social
media as a shock but in fact it has a
long history um that actually two
countries uh have tried very hard to
rebuild uh relations okay but what does
turkey get out of this
well
turkey
i think a very very important country in
the middle east and instrumental for
peace and prosperity let's remember that
mediating between uh in the past israel
and
syria when things went really bad for uh
syrians so in fact the relations despite
all these um
crisis continued um i i remember last
march when herzog visited ankara the
trade volume was 8.5 billion between the
two countries and they they said they
wished to see that it was over 10 000.
so there is no or not only economic
reason in my view
but actually uh the good ties between
the countries in the past
benefited the region enormously as a
person i traveled many times from jordan
passing to to israel i benefited you can
see it is very very important and it was
upsetting uh to see these relations
severely in the past so it is going to
certainly have economic benefits no
doubt about it tourism will uh flourish
more and more is where the tourists will
be coming trade and business volumes and
maybe military cooperation but that in
my view also signifies turkey is kind of
steadily becoming part of abraham
accords signed
between the u.s during the trump
administration and the gulf states and
it seems it's it's really developing and
region has very high expectations so
turkey being part of it uh will
certainly contribute positively
thank you very much for your insight
that is vaiby basan from istanbul